but you're being an ish I'm vegan is
here
how's that going for you
um it's cool
I was saying like because you were like
man I'm trying to be vegan and I most
people who are you know you're a big guy
most people go vegan to try to lose
weight and I'm like well you're still
kind of a big guy so how's it going like
what was the reason so
it's because I just want to eat cleaner
you know what I'm saying that was like
the most part I just want to eat cleaner
and then if I lost weight then that
would have been a bonus well I just want
to eat cleaner though
did you end up eating cleaner did you
end up eating cereal and chips and [ __ ]
no I don't eat I I I eat a lot of vegan
food but here and there I have an oxtail
or right you know what I'm saying [ __ ]
like that so you uh Dibble and Dabble in
the vegan lifestyle yeah yeah I Dibble
in it yeah what's your favorite vegan
fake thing because you know they got
these vegan wings that aren't Wings it's
like just call them whatever they are I
can't eat that [ __ ] do you like
fried chicken got to be fried chicken I
eat um impossible burgers or anything
and possible Whopper is fire it's better
than a real Whopper I don't know about
that have anybody who had an impossible
Whopper
lawyer Burger King where you think they
got Whoppers
Mo you had the impossible Whopper
yeah it tastes better though it tastes
better tastes more charred more charred
hey I respect it would you rank uh
because Burger King is uh
as a guy who's a fellow guy who enjoys
fast food I want some Burger King though
I [ __ ] with Burger King those chicken
fries
I was gonna ask you give me all the
major chains
major chains only rank the top five fast
food restaurants
top fast food restaurants
Chick-fil-A is the most consistent
number one the most consistent okay
Raising Cane's okay they bread there is
like no other it's the cane sauce yeah
that cane sauce hits different for sure
yeah he waiting on me to say in and out
I'm not gonna say it
so Raising Cane's Chick-fil-A I'm at a
great start right now
I'll be two for two for sure
um now things get hairy okay okay it's a
drop off now
Shake Shack really Shake Shack got fire
Ass Burgers and chicken sandwiches
but isn't Shake Shack there's no
drive-throughs not fast food
disqualified give me another Choice okay
now listen now listen right
and I'm gonna say McDonald's because
since we had McDonald's the first time
yeah to the last time
they always had the best fries
listen I got McDonald's at number one
you're preaching to the choir okay all
right it's literally the greatest fast
food restaurant of all time you ever had
it you ever had a fish fillet sandwich
with Mac sauce no chocolate I've had
every type of [ __ ] house
it was great it was beautiful okay get
the full slice of cheese okay bit yeah
boom boom boom what's next Burger King
okay
now we got the the five spot I don't
know you putting Burger King in the five
oh yeah I don't know so we got the top
three
damn I want to say KFC but they chicken
fake
but I gotta buy our chickens at Popeyes
Popeyes Popeyes some have drive-throughs
I'll I'll take it I Popeyes
Del Taco [ __ ] Adam
fifth spot
fifth spot
gotta have a drive through gotta have a
drive-through
Starbucks
I respect it
Starbucks you hating on Taco Bell though
Taco Bell bro let me tell you Taco Bell
Taco Bell is the type of person
tell me what type of person I am Taco
Bell is the type of person to do
something just because everybody else
doing it oh I see what you said I love
Taco Bell like oh and what world do Taco
Bell sell Fried Chicken
they have Fried Chicken now yes Wings
yeah yes wow they don't I never thought
I'd see that in my life I like Taco Bell
because it really feels like they're
just taking all the homies and just
getting them [ __ ] up on [ __ ]
Edibles and weed and they're like hey
what would y'all want to eat and then
they put that on the menu you know what
though that fiery Taco they had though
that [ __ ] was undefeated like
they put the Dorito on yeah of course
and then they put Fritos inside of
burritos and [ __ ] yeah no fire you want
that was the one I like yeah I think
McDonald's is uh they still got them
they still got them yeah they got the
red tacos I might have to go grab one of
them yeah no for sure I might have to
grab a shield and take the impossible
Whopper meat and put it in there have
you ever done that cross-pollinated fast
food streams
um like maybe you get the [ __ ] fries
from McDonald's and you go to Wendy's
and get a frosty that might be actually
crazy though imagine McDonald's fries
inside of the frosty from Wendy's that's
crazy yeah you get the best fries and
then you get the Frosty and you go boom
that's the fact I might have to see
what's up yeah well now we understand
why vegans kind of got you running in
place wait what yeah yeah yeah yeah I
feel like um
I like I was you ever had a corned beef
sandwich of course
after last I I can use a corned beef
sandwich right now you ever have chicken
beef
is that [ __ ] in a jar and you eat it
with gravy and toast it's like breakfast
yeah corned beef hash obviously with the
potatoes I never had chicken beef though
you ever like just you know they got the
can that was kind of like one of the
go-to meals just the canned corned beef
hash put it in a [ __ ] pan throw some
eggs on top yeah we bought the laundry
company and we're gonna have like fried
chicken in the can he got Hood about you
already so it's like the Hibachi
um wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait
fried chicken in a can yeah you gotta
explain to me how that [ __ ] makes any
kind of sense that sounds like goddamn
so basically salmonella so we're gonna
fry the chicken
and we're gonna put it in a can and
um we're gonna put paper towel in there
so the grease can catch you know what
I'm saying okay
um seal that [ __ ] up and it's gonna have
like a a weak expiration on it
so if it don't get bought in a week it's
over if you don't give up we eat it
you'll eat it yeah yeah have you thought
about doing a ghost kitchen thing what's
that so if you're going like uh
Postmates ubereats you probably noticed
like Wiz Khalifa has his own restaurant
on there Khalid has a restaurant uh
Tiger has a restaurant uh so it's
essentially you would start your own
restaurant
and then a kitchen that isn't a real
restaurant it's just a kitchen like a
commercial kitchen they'll fulfill your
orders for you come up with your menu
you could call it like Grizzly bites or
whatever yeah yeah that's right like
with your with your following online
like I feel like the kids would be like
yo [ __ ] yeah and you could plug that
[ __ ] on Twitch all day oh [ __ ] that
might be hard no cat do it man you never
did
um a weed uh weed strain I did in
Detroit it was exclusive in Detroit
though I never did one out here yeah but
I do want to do some [ __ ] out here
though
talking about that who's talking about
that I don't know
if you're gonna do the voice oh yeah
that would be dope yeah yeah
I was just talking about she's Asian she
has to know the backpack boys
by the way shout out to Gramercy they
just signed up the backpack boys
oh run Sky okay yeah okay get it
together man yeah called grizzly bears
okay grizzly bear is just fire Grizzly
Berry oh yeah heat Grizzly berries yeah